it's now my great honor and privilege to
introduce dr. Georges Benjamin who's the
executive director of the American
Public Health Association who has a long
and distinguished career both as a
medical professional and as a public
health professional please give a warm
welcome to dr. Georges Benjamin hey
David how are you I am good how are you
dr. Benjamin and I'm here hanging in
there
good thing about well we we know that
the theme of the moment is is reopening
I would say we just heard one
possibility for that but obviously a lot
of countries have already reopened in
one form or another and I believe as of
today all 50 states and here in the US
have reopened in one form or another how
do we do that smartly how do we do that
safely yeah we really do need to reopen
safely and carefully and it means that
we have to we have not got to forget
these public health measures that that
really brought down the curve to begin
with that means things such as
covering up your nose and mouth and your
office needs wearing a mask
washing your hands physically just and
seeing yourself to the extent possible
from others you know thinking about
everything we do you know before we go
to work in the morning while we're at
work and being as careful as many of us
have been in the last two months as we
go into the next three months because
this thing is not over right there is
the chance of more waves as as URI
mentioned it seems like it's kind of
incumbent on all of us then to take
public health as kind of a second job is
that
is that right you know I've been arguing
a lot that now that everybody really
knows what public healthy is that
everybody should recognize that their
second job is public health whether
you're picking up the garbage or working
in a grocery store or you are a bus
driver or you're you know like me doing
public health physician or a nurse
everybody needs have put the public
health Mantaro into what they do each
and every day what do you think the so
we're all public health professionals
now what do you think the the new normal
we might expect as countries reopen what
is that gonna look like or what do you
hope that looks like as a public health
professional yeah effect I'm a wave a
magic wand I would clearly you know
recognize that people are going to be
doing a lot more of the the public
health things in terms of of hand
washing and thinking about what they do
around safety when they go out in public
you know there was not too long ago when
you got in your car and you didn't put
your seat belt on and you know today we
do it and we don't think anything about
right most of us don't smoke because we
know that that's bad for us most of us
look both ways we put me across the
street
most of us you know do things who are a
house that a fixed trip hazards so as we
go forward with this outbreak I'm hoping
that people will pay a lot more
attention to things that can cause us to
get an infection so you know cleaning
things just affecting things more
importantly not coming to work if you
sick I'm hoping that employers will put
in paid sick leave for everybody so
people can stay home yeah it's an
additional cost but I can tell you that
we've now learned that the cost of not
doing something like that is billions
and billions and billions of dollars
basically there's pretty cheap when you
do that yeah we are I think envious in
the United States of all the countries
that the
perhaps have a more all-encompassing
healthcare system than we do would you
agree that masks are kind of the symbol
of that adopting that public health
professional is a second job mindset
well you know it's funny so you know our
colleagues in Asia have had a mass
wearing mask as a culture for many many
many years and you know we've always
kind of chuckled at that
when I went over when overseas I was
talking to an instructor when I saw
people wearing masks and of course when
this first started you know we only
promoted masks from people that were
infected or course health care workers
who we thought were in a higher risk
environment but I think that that where
mass is probably going to be part of our
culture we've already seen and probably
will not be part of our beach culture
although it probably should be for now
but I do think that we're going to see
more and more people wearing masks in a
variety of settings and I think that
makes sense yeah where your math to show
that you care about others and that you
have this kind of Public Health spirit
so speaking of Asia who has who has done
well looking around the world and you've
been doing this for a while and and
communicated with your peers who has
done well and what can we learn from
those good examples
yeah South Korea in many ways is the
role model you know China actually at
the end of the day did reasonably well
but the secret to all of those countries
that have had a less morbidity mortality
we have is they did lots of testing very
early on they did contact tracing and
isolation and Quarantine which by the
way is the bedrock of Public Health
practice they've done they did it early
they did a lot of it and by the way even
though they're reopening their society
and they're beginning to see episodic
surges they then go back to those basic
Public Health practices of testing
isolation contact tracing and and
transparency to the public when they
because it's important for the public to
understand how many cases they are where
the disease is if you're going to get
compliance in the public so testing
contact tracing and isolation that
doesn't seem like rocket science to use
that old cliche why has that been hard
for for some countries to to implement
what's what's holding us back is it
electronic medical records is that some
fancy doodad or is it just maybe
overconfidence based on maybe the public
health successes of the last hundred
years you know we have been we're very
much a Peel society we think does appeal
for everything if we can't give you a
pill for it then we can give you surgery
and fix it you know prevention works and
we have totally under invested in
prevention we have totally under
invested in a strong robust public
health system if you look at the fact
that in America today you can still you
can very easily know what's coming off
the shelf of a grocery store
Amazon knows everything there is to know
about you but your doctor does not have
the same tools three o'clock in the
morning it's still very difficult to get
a hold of your electric cardiogram or
your medical record or your list of
allergies if you can't tell the
practitioner what you have and we just
have an invested in robust systems one
of the interesting things about this
outbreak is that it has created an
environment in which we now dependent on
telemedicine which has been around for
several years but we weren't quite into
it but now it's probably going to be the
new standard but it also seems so
obviously those those countries with an
incredibly robust healthcare system like
Taiwan have have done well but it seems
like even countries that perhaps would
be considered to have a less robust
health care system like a Ghana in
Africa have actually done well what has
been the I guess the the secret sauce
for those kinds of countries yeah it's
still pretty early in
and some of their exposures and
hopefully they might not have a wave
that comes later that's still a
possibility but at the end of the day I
think to the extent you have done good
sound public health practices all over
the countries that have done well have
implemented that now we're a big country
we're a complex country and yes we
didn't get the testing right to begin
with but we should not repeat the
mistakes that we had at the last three
months because we still got several
months to go and now that we know what
we did wrong I've encouraged you notes
to do it right the next time I mean
that's Mart tomorrow okay that's right
that's right
it's already started I mean it almost
seems to me if I can use this metaphor
that some of these countries already had
the kind of antibodies in their system
because I had experience with maybe
Ebola or or the first SARS is is that
the key previous exposure to these kind
of public health crises well this is a
very different virus and and while there
may be some early evidence that mirrors
and SARS one I have we may have some
protection early protection from that
and if some early early studies looking
at that that's not the solution the
secret sauce here is a good solid public
health practice that's the secret sauce
here we should not be looking for
anything any any any mysticism or anyone
that comes with a special feel this is
all about good solid public health
practice because by the way look this
one was a bad one but it's not the last
one
and so we need to prepare for the next
really big one we think this one was bad
imagine what would have happened had
Ebola been aerosolized or mirrors have
been been aerosolized you know pick a TV
movie we even though we this was a bad
one we still dodged a really really
really bad one this time yeah Middle
East respiratory syndrome is is no joke
and we should be thankful that that it
doesn't spread more easily like SARS
Kobe is this though so all these
diseases are zoo
that means they you know jump to us from
the animals are out there obviously
humanity is kind of encroaching on
nature in an ever-more kind of urgent
way whether that's climate change or or
or going into the forest what what have
you is this just the new normal like we
should expect pandemics every so often
well they do come periodic you know
periodically so this is not you know
this is not the first pandemic right we
had we've had several we had the hundred
years ago the 1918 influenza of SARS was
a significant infection even though it
didn't get this bad SARS one and we had
avian flu which was which was a
challenge and the swine flu
we had Zika so know we've had several
new disease outbreaks these emerging
diseases happen a lot and in many ways
we've been fortunate that we have been
able to identify them early and contain
them but we're now in an environment
where people can by the way make some of
these things up now this one did not
happen as best we can tell it's not
man-made it did not probably come out of
a leak in the lab but we know that when
I was in school to grow above you had to
be pretty sophisticated that's not the
case today and we need to protect
ourselves from both naturally occurring
infections and from those that are
created by humans plus we have other
kind of threat multipliers like like
climate change that make pandemics like
this not much worse you know I was
saying climate change was the greatest
threat to human survival before this one
but this is rivaling climate change but
let me tell you the big challenge we
have now is that we have a pandemic
which we've still not contained as we
enter hurricane season and we have i'ma
change which is exacerbating the
ferocity of the hurricanes that we're
having so you know we
we're gonna we're in for an interesting
summer and here's Chris with I think a
question from our audience many
questions actually we people have very
interested in what you're saying George
is here we go here's the festival from
Jim young how do we deal with people who
don't believe this is serious you know
you just have to continue to communicate
the truth to folks you know one of the
things about this particular disease is
that it does not spare anyone it does
not recognize political parties who does
not recognize geography and we had lots
of people particularly in rural
communities that we're not seeing it
because it had not yet come to them and
they didn't believe it was real and now
many of those communities are being
ravaged by this disease and so we just
have to you know it's not appropriate to
say I told you so it is appropriate to
say look now that you see it come on
board and help us you know resolve these
problems but this is something that's
going to be around for a while and if it
becomes endemic meaning that it occurs
all the time at some low level
everyone's going to have this experience
thank you here is one from Robert
percolates we seem to have been ignoring
an underfunding public health and we
were underprepared for unprepared for
this virus but if the question is gonna
pop up there I think it should buy it so
magic what should our priorities be now
to prepare for the next public health
crisis well we don't now need to make
sure that we've put in note the funding
resources training staffing on the table
and and by the way I next public health
crisis is not 10 years from now it's not
20 years from now it's the the potential
co-occurrence
of influenza which we know is going to
happen this fall because it comes every
year with either continued kovat or a
spiking Colvin
and we're going to have a disease
process which presents very much the
same and we're going to have to
differentiate covet from influenza
because we have a vaccine for influenza
we don't yet have a vaccine for covet we
hope to have one in about a year
but that still remains to be seen so get
your function affect yeah
and indeed if David different Collins
asked exactly that question what is the
likelihood of a vaccine before the next
wave well you know the the fastest
vaccine that we've ever developed with
measles and that took four years now we
a lot of people different right we have
started on a SARS one vaccine so it had
gone through a lot of animal trials that
had gone through some early very very
early human trials as you know we just
got some announcement that at least it
does seem to work in monkeys and in
rhesus monkeys and there's some evidence
that at least it may be efficacious and
safe in a very very small number of
people when I say very very small number
of people handful of people so now he's
got to go to phase 2 and phase 3 trials
so yeah Krista held up two hands oh yeah
yeah it's a small number of what that
tells you is either that those folks
were very lucky or it works and we won't
know what we put this in mm into the
arms of thousands of people here's an
important question from a TED fellow how
do we actually train people about what
public health means especially in the
context of folks who don't believe they
have a responsibility to the public well
IIIi I remind folks that public health
public health does lose best job nothing
happens and of course when nothing
happens we don't get credit for so the
reason that you everyone in this country
does not have to get up every morning
and boil their own water is because of
Public Health the reason that when you
if you get her to a car accident you
know and get an automobile collision and
you wear your seatbelt and you have
airbags
and you're not you're not killed from
that automobile collision is because of
public health the reason that the air is
safe to breathe the food is safe to eat
is because of Public Health the reason
that your kids are not in clothing that
ignites is because we have fire
retardant clothing and that is a
requirement the reason that you don't
ship walking down the stairs is because
we've actually looked at how to build a
stair so that people don't trip when
they go up or down that's actually a
public health intervention so the built
in rutte grip medicines all those kinds
of things
vaccines those are all public health and
and that's why public health is there
and you may not believe that it's that
important but we couldn't live it out it
maybe one day we can all envision a
system a public health care system in
America that actually has some
incentives the point towards public
health that would be very nice David I
gotta just keep going with some of these
questions if it's okay because that
they're pouring in there's one here from
Jacqueline Ashby important question for
every parent what are your
recommendations about sending children
back to school
yeah I'm struggling with this one I've
got three grandkids um and good news
with my grandkids are more technically
proficient than I am and right now are
getting their lessons remotely I think
it's gonna be a challenge as we think
about sending kids back to school we're
gonna really need to know how infectious
kids are and how well they do when they
get infected now right now and it sees
it seems except for a very small number
of children who get a very rare disease
that they tolerate this disease very
well but but the central question is how
many of these germs are these kids bring
back to you and to Grandma and Grandpa
so that's going to be important and you
know trying to tell a eight-year-old not
to interact with their friends is a real
challenge by the way try to tell the
seventeen year old
and that they're gonna rap with their
fans a challenge so we got to properly
educate these kids we got to figure out
how we stagger their their schedules
URIs idea for the workforce might be an
interesting concept for schools because
the idea is to try to decompress the
number of kids in the classroom well by
the way if you get smaller class size
and get better education anyway
so we've got to have enough teachers up
so that that may be the rate limiting
step alright last question here for now
from Steve photonic mosques advise a
mosque whoops I switch that off there we
go advice our mosques citiship shifted
what would would most Americans who live
in Woking cities be better off wearing
masks to also help reduce the atom
particles they encounter every day it
may help some absolutely um but let me
tell you what I would prefer we stop
doing burning fossil fuels and I'll do
it all those terrible things that we are
doing to destroy our climate if you know
everyone's talking about the fact that
yeah we've had this amazing reduction in
co2 because we're not driving cars um I
gotta tell you that is the best evidence
that climate change is man-made all
those climate change skeptics who don't
think climate change is man-made we have
just had a worldwide demonstration on
what people do to create climate change
and so what we need to do is stop and
move to a green economy
thank you so much for those I'll get
back it at the end with maybe a couple
more thank you for this
so we're waving the flag for masks but
also one of the things that has become
clear from this is that Kovan 19 is is
not the great leveler that maybe some
had hoped it was some communities are
experiencing much worse significantly
worse outcomes than others why why is
that well we're talking principally
about the african-american and Latino
communities that
seem to be disproportionately impacted
if they get the disease and it's because
of exposure primarily those populations
have more public facing jobs so you know
bus drivers grocery clerks working in
long-term care facilities nursing homes
in meatpacking facilities chicken farms
so that's why they're much more going to
be exposed to the disease susceptibility
lots of chronic disease so we know that
particular African Americans have
disproportionate amounts of diabetes
heart disease lung disease and because
of those chronic diseases we've found
early on that that virus is more
detrimental to those populations that
have those diseases and so that's the
big issue here that is what's causing
those differentiations and it's really a
challenge because in many ways those are
many of the people that we can have
decided our essential employees and have
to go to work that's right
so what is in your view the public
health intervention to protect these
essential workers if you if you have
ideas on that front yeah I absolutely do
so we don't we started this by by a a
testing strategy based on symptoms and
now we need to now that we have enough
tests we need to make sure that not only
people get those tests for clinical
reasons and people who have symptoms but
also begin to prioritize people who are
public-facing who are essential workers
so certainly people working in nursing
homes hospitals etc but bus drivers
security guards grocery store clerks
they need to be tested and they didn't
have to test it with the curiosity that
will secure them their families and give
everyone to trust that they're not going
to be infected and we're not going to
infect them people who work in meat pop
meat packing plants as an example and
we've seen the real tragedy of what's
going on the meatpacking plants because
they are working in an environment where
they're sold in the shoulder there are
some other things they need to do in
terms of
figuring out how to give them physical
distancing on the assembly line that's
gonna be important but again your EES
idea it's not a bad idea for them for
this nation to consider from any of
those industries to think about yeah we
have to make sure that these truly are
folks who are treated as essential
workers not sacrificial workers it seems
to me and obviously this is not just
confined to the US oh absolutely
absolutely
we're seeing these disparities not just
in United States but in other countries
as well and they have a lot to do with
with with race and class and the types
of jobs that you do the occupations that
you do and quite frankly we should have
thought about this when we when we saw
the first data that showed that in China
that people who had chronic diseases
were much more at risk it had worse
health outcomes we should have we've got
to spin up our actions right away
because look that's happened with every
new diseases coming the country so it
seems like a lot of this goes back to
that potential that it's not an oxymoron
public health is everybody's job and and
we need to adopt that what does a in
your view a robust public health
infrastructure look like what would that
look like well you know anytime a new
health threat enters our community we
ought to be able to rapidly identify it
contain it and if we can mitigate it for
sure and eliminate it if possible and
then put in all the protective measures
that we have before so that means having
a well staffed well trained governmental
Public Health entity just like we have
for Police Fire EMS it means that
they've got to be well-paid that means
that they've got to be well resourced
you know we still have some of our
contact tracers out there using pin and
pads and silly things to Excel
spreadsheets
know we need the same kind of robust
technology that the folks at
you know any the the online retailers to
you and whether it's Amazon etc
et-cetera we're still looking at data
that's two years in the rear to make
data-driven decisions we need to be able
to make immediate decisions probably
Taiwan you mentioned them earlier I
remember being in Taiwan watching data
come from infectious diseases real-time
from their electronic medical record
system so you know we can do this the
technology exists imagine that Wow
real-time health information what a what
a difference that would that would make
do you think that technology can can can
can help us here whether that's the
Google Apple collaboration or whatever
else technology can help us but we is
not going to replace us we're not we're
nowhere near where we can sit back and
have our our our electronic avatar do
our work for us but the technology
because it can give us situational
awareness if you give us real-time
information it allows us to send
information from point A to point B for
for data analysis it allows us to do
second thinking so we doing all this
modeling it allows others to do the to
check our numbers right away so he could
speed up research but we have to invest
in it and we have to continue it because
obsolescence is always the the evil part
of technology and it looks like Chris is
back with more questions yep I guess
we're getting close to the end of the
questions Keith keep coming in there's
this one here from Neil a but what role
do you see parks trails and open space
play in assisting larger public health
goals you know green space is absolutely
essential and the ability to get out and
walk and exercise having sidewalks so
that you can have communities that are
walkable bikable and green for people
utilization of all ages it's good for
our mental health is good for our
physical health
and you know I always tell folks you
know it's a great place to go when
someone's gotten on your last nerve
indeed here we have one anonymous
question where possible don't go
anonymous because we're all friends here
what I'll send down and probably someone
anyway let's see but there's a good
question
there are many who are highly suspicious
of what the real experts are saying what
have you found to be effective in
helping the highly suspicious be less
suspicious and more trusting tell the
truth if you make a mistake acknowledge
it and correct it right away be
consistent and don't stay some say
stupid stuff and and far too often that
happens and you know one of the
interesting things we've already been
through this with the masked discussion
you know traditional wisdom was that we
only had people wear the mask if they
were infectious or you were in a health
care environment where there was a high
risk of getting the disease and then we
said no it's okay for everybody to wear
a mask and that's because we learned
eventually and became much much more
believable in the science that we had
asymptomatic spreading but we did not
communicate it very well you know we
said oh no no we're changing our minds
everybody can wear a mask after telling
people not to wear a mask and then we
didn't spend enough time explaining to
people why so we lost trust so we need
to do a better job of that and then our
frankly our leaders need to be very
careful what they say when you have a
bullhorn and by the way I've made
mistakes I've said things on TV was just
wrong because I was wrong and I've tried
it very hard you try to correct those as
quickly as I can
all of us do that but you have to be
strong enough and have a strong enough
personality to to say when you're wrong
and then correct it because at the end
of the day once you've lost trust you've
lost everything
well if I might say so just the way in
which you're communicating right now I
mean to me that is a means of
communication that engenders trust I
don't know what magic sauce you have
going there but it's it's it's very very
compelling listening to you thank you so
much for for this David do you have any
other last ques yeah I realize it's yeah
no but it really has been a real
pleasure to have you join us and thank
you for that just one final question if
I may
you've been doing this for a while what
gives you hope looking forward you know
let me tell you something the one thing
that gives me hope is when I see people
taking care of their fat their friends
and family members I mean you know drive
by birthday parties I saw that on the
news today people who are calling their
friends I've heard from people that I
haven't talked to in years who just
called me to say I haven't talked to you
for a long time are you okay so do more
of that and I get to trust we've had in
one another and the love we shown is
just been absolutely amazing say give me
all humanity for the win in the end
yep yeah well thank you so much dr.
Benjamin for joining us and for sharing
your wisdom glad to be here thank you
absolutely you guys be safe your Falcons
be safe thank you you too all right